So you remember when I was
talking about Europe, uh,
we discussed the fact
that during marriage, uh,
Europeans just had babies
in a sense willy nilly,
but we all said it was nowhere near
the maximum that humans are capable of,
but we thought it was no
sort of cultural constraints,
late marriage and stuff like that.
Now we come to China in which the birth
rate within marriage was quite a bit
lower.
And I introduced the question of whether
this was voluntary in the sense of
individually decided individual decides
what they want and act on it or was this
low birth rate, uh, due to
a cultural constraints, uh,
in a crowded household would maybe
the grandmother sleeping beneath you,
there's no opportunity if the cultural
rules say you can't be friends with your
wife, there may be a reduction in
passion. And the conclusion that I,
that I gave you was that this didn't
seem to be an individual decision kind of
thing, but a cultural kind of
thing. Let me one of the eye,
it's a little bit out of, out of
place, but I just can't, I can't,
I have to love this data so much.
It's so,
it's so very striking as an example
of people that are not individually,
voluntarily controlling their fertility.
So how would you tell if someone is,
you know, you have a big huge
population, uh, you don't,
you can't interview all of them. Maybe
it's a dead population, know the old,
uh, how do you tell a, whether
they're making individual decisions?
Well you have,
one of the ways of doing is to consider
individual events in their lives that
you think under any reasonable idea of
what it is to be a human would affect
their fertility.
And one of those events
is a death of a child.
There's many, there's a, I mean,
I think you all would naturally say if
you want a certain number of children are
going to control consciously.
If your children die,
you're going to try harder to have more,
you're going to try longer.
So here is a Chinese population from 1982.
So we're talking about just at the time
when the one child policy is starting
and these are women who have finished
their childbearing by 1980 82 so it's the
generation exactly prior to the one child
policy and it gives you a lot of data.
But look over here it says what happened
to the first four children and it gives
you two cases.
All all the children died or all survive.
There's a lot of intermediate cases which
which are not shown in this particular
graph and it's spread out by age to
seeing if there's some sort of age effect.
And here is the mother's
age at laughed last birth.
So if all of them survived,
if all of them died,
you think the mother would
really want to have more.
She stops giving birth at 30 at age 38.7
if they all survived one 10th of the
year, she stopped giving birth
one 10th of a year earlier,
one month earlier,
same if the a little bit older group,
you have a point for a year,
maybe four months later and
here's 0.1 months. Again,
for women who are 20, uh, a their age
at first birth, I'm sorry. They, it,
it,
the age of which they stopped depends on
the age at which they start to a large
degree.
So the numbers are this way different
because they started at different ages,
but there's no difference within an age
group on whether all four children died
or all four children survived. That's
just to me, that's a, an amazing, uh,
set of statistics that apparently the,
the continuation,
the attempt to have as many children
as possible, just as not depend on,
on that event.
Here's another example of this.
This is, uh, as well as custom.
Most of Asia, a lot of the world,
and especially China,
they need males.
Sons are much preferred over daughters.
So here's a crazy,
very nicely displayed, a set of data, uh,
saying how many sons have you
had? How many daughters, here's,
uh, that have had no sun or no
daughter? And the question is,
how many of them proceed these numbers
or the fraction that proceed to have the
first birth? So when they get
married and they have no children,
neither sun nor daughter point, uh, 0.95,
eight, I'm sorry. They
have, they have a son first.
They have one son or one daughter.
Those that have a son,
95.8% of them proceed to have a second
child and then that can be the a boy or a
girl.
If their first child is a daughter,
96.8% proceed.
So you don't have to look up here and the
details aren't important. But look at,
for instance,
those that have seven sons in a row,
this is people that have seven and 72%
72 and a half percent of them proceed to
get pregnant. Again, here's
seven daughters in a row.
They want the sons,
they want daughters,
76% a three and a half percent difference.
Almost no difference in their life.
Again,
how many of them after having seven sons,
you're presumed that it's enough.
I have a sense, whereas seven daughters,
they would be desperate to have more,
but there's a very small different,
a a 3% difference between the
fraction of them that proceed.
And you can also see the
numbers are very high.
Those that have had seven children are
already 76% proceeded to have another
birth.
They just keep going.
And whether they have all daughters in
a row or all sons in a row makes very
little difference.
Finally at eight there is,
it is a 10% different,
less less than 10% difference,
but whether that,
that doesn't fit with the
rest of the bath, but it's
still very small difference.
And here's the last graph of this,
of this nature.
And this is again the me, the age of
the mother's last birth. And again,
it's the same kind of graph,
uh,
those that have had eight daughters in
a row versus those that have eight sons
in a row.
And you think in a sun desire in culture,
if they were controlling their fertility
in any individualistic way that the
ones with a lot of sons I would
say, okay enough. You know,
and the ones with a lot of daughters
would be desperate to finally have a son.
But look at the difference.
41, the age of 41.4.
If they have eight sons in a
row and the age 41.7, again,
three tenths of a year, the
they try just a little bit, uh,
longer, uh, three months
longer. So basically,
I think what this data is telling you is
that people are for sure not responding
to their most important
fertility events in their life,
either the sex composition of their
children or the death of the children.
They're just, uh, having, having
children at not an enormous rate
because of the cultural things that
everybody is, is, is behaving under,
not with respect to their
individual experiences and desires.
Okay. So this is the context
into which the one child,
the first,
the one she shouted,
the later longer fewer policy drops in
and then 10 years later the one child
policy.
So it gives you an amazing,
here's a population that just finished
childbearing when the policy starts and
there's apparently no thought whatsoever
of individually controlling, uh,
fertility. And all of a sudden the
government tells you, you know, hey,
you gotta you gotta you
got to have fewer children.
And I showed you the rate of fall.
The rate of fall during the
70s was just a fantastic.
And then after that fall, again, as I
told you last time to control momentum,
uh,
they institute the one child policy
and the number of births levels off.
And why does the number
of births level off? Uh,
this is again the fertility drop.
Uh,
this is the longer later
fuehler a policy in the 1970s.
That's where you get the big
drop. 1980, the one child policy,
you don't get any further drops.
And that was a sign of,
well,
uh,
an incompetent government incompetently
carried out fertility policy that turns
out the one arm of the government was
doing something the opposite to the
opposite fact, have another arm
of the government. So here the,
the Chinese were,
uh,
for women's rights issues and uh,
to,
to control somewhat
control the population.
They are encouraging later marriage that
didn't want girls married at 13, 14,
15 and so forth. So we've
been very successful. The
revolution is, is out here.
Uh,
and the age of marriage is already
up to 19 and a half or so by 1965.
And they're being very successful.
And the age of marriage keeps going up
until it reaches a quite respectable 23
that's older than basically all you are.
So most of you,
not at all who it reaches a peak there.
Then what does the government do?
It says, well, we're doing
great. We're now very worried.
This is the year where they introduced
the one child policy. Uh, we want to,
uh, this to continue on up so
they don't have good demographics,
statistics,
and they don't know this data.
They don't actually know what age
people are actually marrying at.
So they have an official age which
was actually above this and they,
they they,
I'm sorry it was both.
They raised that age to
prevent more marriages.
But since people were below
that, uh, what happened was,
let's say I'm getting this backwards.
They anyway, the result of a, of a policy,
they had the opposite result that result
of instituting new policy and tended to
raise marriage age,
reduced marriage age said.
And then you see when they
introduced the one child policy,
the mean age of marriage goes down,
it goes down quite significantly.
So the one child policy saying you have,
should have fewer children is working
oppositely two new policy that actually
reduces the age at marriage
and increases the span.
And the result is this is the number
of new marriages of first marriages and
there's a rise here.
Then it's kind of dipsy doodles.
And then just in time
for the one child policy,
the number of new marriages goes crazy
and this big rise in the number of
marriages.
And remember 98% of Chinese wind when
they get married get pregnant right away.
So the next year they have babies.
This counteracts basically all of the
effect of the one child policy and that's
one branch of government
making one set of laws, not,
not having the data and not know and not
being in accord with what another set
of government is doing. And
in fact, the one child policy,
I don't want to leave you
with the impression that
the one child policy had no
effect. Uh, but you have
to do different statistics.
Remember the total fertility rate takes
all the women that are in an age group,
whether they're married or not, and asked
how many children they're having. Well,
when you have a big change in
the fraction of women married,
then you have to do use a different
statistic. And when you change, uh,
when the age of marriage changes
as it didn't in China at that time,
you have to now look at a new statistic
called the parity progression ratio,
which is very much like those
triangle graphs that I showed you.
This says this black line, uh, is,
uh,
how many that proceed from having
no children to having one child,
the fracture of the fraction of women.
And this is in the 95% range or something.
Basically all the Chinese women at
this time when they get married,
give birth to their first child.
Now the next number is those
that already have one child.
What fraction of them
proceed to have two children?
And the answer is before,
before this policy, uh,
even more than the one that you know,
98% of of women that
already have one child, uh,
proceed to have a second child.
And that may be that in this group
are a fairly, are sterile women,
are sterile men. And so that may
be the difference between here,
but we don't have that data. So
again, this is very, very high.
And then the other numbers, those
that have two children, what,
how many go to three?
Those that have three children,
how many go to four or more and so forth.
And we don't have data before this,
but you can see that the
first child is uninterrupted.
The one she showered, the later longer,
fewer policy. And the one child policy,
uh, does not interrupt the first
birth that goes on as normal,
which is what is expected.
But going to a second child now at the
time of the introduction of the one child
policy,
this,
this crashes as does later births.
And so the one child policy
did have an effect, uh,
if you look at those who are already
married, but the two different policies,
one lowering the age of
marriage counteracts the
effect. And for number of years,
the fertility rate stays constant.
And we've just had some visitors, oh,
let me show you what that was
talking about. This is the,
the birth rate in China that what's
called the total fertility rate.
And here's 1970,
when the later longer,
fewer policy was introduced and it
was the decade of the 1970s where the
fertility rate in China fell in 1979,
1980 the one child policy is introduced
and for about a decade or so,
the birth rate does not decrease under
that. So we have some guests apparently.
Okay. So, uh,
what was happening was that in the,
in the cities, as I mentioned, uh,
there was a very significant
birth drop in the 60s,
even before the government was on then
the 70s during lunch Shao the city
populations went down to below fertility
level. Uh, but in the countrysides,
even though there was a big drop in,
in the 70s,
it wasn't anything like
it was in the cities.
And as you heard from a chain who,
who talked about her family's experience,
uh, in the cities, there were many
people that worked for the government.
And so we're under tight
government control.
Many of them work in government owned
factories or in tight government control.
And in general in cities,
uh,
there is much more ability
to control the people.
However, at that time, 80% of
Chinese people lived in villages.
It was still a very rural a country.
And they're the store.
So the story is different among
other things in many villages,
all the people that are related,
they're all relatives. So, uh,
the professor who's got the next lab too,
mine is named John and his village.
Everybody's, you're young.
And they're all related.
So if people don't
believe, uh, in a policy,
they don't want to obey the government
and everybody's related, you know, your,
your uncle second removed can't really
enforce a policy on you if your relative,
especially in a,
in a culture where kinship means so much.
And the relationship between
relatives, uh, mean so much.
So, uh, the, the, the,
the one child policy was much, much
less successful, uh, in the countryside.
Similarly,
the cities were beginning to have access
jobs and people were screaming out of
the country side also because of
population growth, there was no land left.
So they're streaming out of the country,
countryside going into the cities.
They didn't have, uh, uh, legal,
uh, living permits. They have,
they have a system where you have your
document where you live and you have to
stay there. And they were not allowed
officially to come into the cities,
but of course they did.
And so the government didn't know where
they were and basically had no control
over them. And so they, uh, were,
were very hard to control. So, uh,
yeah,
even though among, uh, so,
and then another thing that happens again
just at this time is that previously
everybody, the peasants had been in
communes. I talked about them last time,
you know, several thousand families in
one big fan farm, uh, and under again,
strict control of the government.
Then that with a great leap forward,
they realize the commune system has failed
and the land goes back to the people.
They break up the communes and
people get their own plot of land.
They don't own it now or sense,
but they have the rights to
work on that plot of land. Well,
they start growing their own food,
private markets for food, uh,
grow up and the people are not getting
everything they need from the government.
So if they really oppose
some government policy,
then they can tell the government by, by,
you know, I don't need anything from you.
I'm now an independent farmer
and I'll do, uh, what I want.
And so the change to a market economy,
the change to more economic freedom
for the individuals led to all kinds of
personal freedom and led to the
ability to say no to the government.
And so you,
you at at the time in the press,
there are all kinds of examples of what
was going on. And uh, for instance,
here's one article from 1980.
Again, I'm sorry this is too,
I'm sorry, the year 2000. So the one child
policy has been in effect for 20 years.
No one can accuse. WHOA sweet. Far,
I'm not knowing what he wanted.
The 47 year old farmer dreamed of
having a son after seven daughters,
he finally got a male
heir in 1989 ho named him.
Why Fang or change in the weather?
And then he stopped having children.
So seven daughters and a son.
So this, this person, most,
almost all of that time must have been
under the one child policy, eight,
eight children. And he says it wasn't
easy to have all these children,
but it wasn't hard either.
The farmer said if things
became tough in our village,
if there was a campaign to enforce the
rule in their village and trying to has
these political campaigns to get people
to change their behavior quite routinely
at this time,
well my wife just went to another township
to have the child and but what's the
other side of the coin is this one now
has a wife and eight children to support
and how much land does he have?
One third of an Acre for eight, nine, 10,
10 people.
This is not a good economic system and
exactly why the one child policy was
instituted.
So an American misconception fed by our
presses that China's government is very
monolithic. The chairman in pay
gang or some bureaucrat, you know,
says this is the rule,
this is the law of spells it out.
Everybody has to obey this
law isn't the case Mo,
there's whole books now on on,
on how China is actually ruled.
And the story is that the
government almost gives a
slogan. So one child policy,
or they sometimes call it the only child
policy is not a set of rules. It's,
it's kind of almost a slogan.
Then it goes down to the provinces and
each province has to determine it in
accord with local conditions as which is
the official way of stating it in each
province, gives it down to the
prefectures and the same thing.
It's interpreted by local
under local conditions.
And then it goes down to the villages
where it's completely changed.
And so there's no absolutely no
uniformity from village to village.
And what that result in it, it was the
policy was never able to be, uh, uh,
uh,
consistently put into practice.
And the statistics give
you the answer to that.
The total fertility rate
during this initial period of,
of enforcement of the one child
policy never fell below two.
So the policy was one child,
but it never fell below two children.
Uh, in the rural areas,
it never fell below 2.5.
There's you saw and a couple of
lectures ago, Ching showed you the, uh,
the one child certificate where there
a couple of promises is just a promise.
This isn't,
say you've done it and just even to
promise that you're only gonna have one
child. And uh, uh,
less than 20% of married couples ever
signed onto even that promise of having
one child, which was
telling the government, no,
we're not going to comply with
this policy throughout the 1980s,
which again was when the policy
was most strictly enforce. Uh,
nearly half of all the births were second,
third or higher order births.
80% of China's children had
brothers or sisters or both. Uh,
many had had had both and,
and only one fifth of 300.
The 300 million children under age
14 were from single child families.
And in 1986, again, after the first
good question, what do you
say? Inconsistent applications?
The one child policy or a reflection
on the pocket, the one child policy.
Never to my understanding then one child,
if you're not enough
both at this time,
initially it was supposed to be one
child for all except minority peoples who
were very small part of the public.
I'll turn minute that they,
because of popular resistance,
they immediately loosened it up.
So the main thing which you're probably
referring to a is that rather rather
soon, uh, they said peasants, the p the,
the city people had already
had their fertility drop.
Many of them were not very interested in
having more than one child who was not
a huge issue for you. One of your readings
discusses that when the countryside,
the peasants still wanted, uh,
certainly a son more children.
So the policy was changed rather rapidly.
So that if you,
if your first child is a daughter,
you can have,
you can have another one and try
for a boy. But two is the limit.
And of course two was,
was not even,
that was not always observed.
Um, so, uh, so the,
remember I told you last time that the
goal when the Chinese population crossed
a billion or was looked like it was,
it was very close to crossing a billion
and the government sort of desperately
wanted to keep the population
below 1.2 billion in the year 2000.
They didn't make it. The population was
1.3 billion, they missed by 100 million.
And now it's a considerably
over over that.
And the population is still growing
because of population momentum. Again,
the age structure of China,
China's population is expected to grow
by another hundred and 50 million people
by 2025.
So even though they've worked so hard
and suffered so much under these various
policies to restrict fertility,
they're still going to increase from
now from 2008 to 2025 by half the total
population of the United States.
And again,
comparable to a calculation
I gave you earlier, uh,
Hu Jintao who was president
of China, uh, recently,
uh,
it says the party plans to quadruple
economic output per capita in that time.
This is before the economic
crash that has just happened,
but he wanted a quadruple,
uh, the per capita income,
which would still bring China up
only to a low European level perhaps.
And so with one,
with a,
a 1.3 billion population
and you're quadrupling it,
that's equal to 5.2 billion.
And the whole population of the
earth is only 6.3. I mean only.
So you're talking about China's
economic and population growth alone,
almost doubling the world's economic
activity and therefore something like
doubling the economic drain on it.
So, uh, China's TFR now,
after this period of stability and
after the marriage thing got settled,
it has drifted down slowly as,
uh,
almost all of the world has.
It's now 1.6. It's still nowhere
near one child per family.
It's 1.6 now.
But that will eventually reduce the
size of the Chinese population if it is
maintained.
But we should keep in mind is
this was the Chinese route,
uh, to, uh, lower population. And I told,
I described to you the popular they
started with that was not paying any
attention to,
to individual desires and fertility.
And they brought it down by
a strong government policy,
good amount of coercion and so forth.
But the Chinese populations around other
parts of East Asia have lowered their
birth rate even more,
or I should say they started Laura,
they reached an even lower level.
So China has 1.6 as I told you,
the Chinese population of Singapore
is 1.4 children per women. Uh,
the Japanese are not Chinese,
obviously 1.3 Taiwan
1.1 South Korea again,
not Chinese 1.3 Hong Kong 1.0 and Macau
1.0 none of these places were under the
one child policy. Actually,
I'm not sure about Macau,
but all the others are not under the
one child policy and they have a lower
birth rate than the Chinese policy.
And we'll have to discuss in a later
lecture why this should be, should be.
So
we wanted to finish up talking
specifically about China, uh,
to mention a little bit
economic globalization, which
you're all aware of. And uh,
because of globalization,
the u s in China joined at the hip,
I mean for the,
for our both our economies to succeed,
we have to buy a lot of Chinese stuff.
They have to buy our bonds,
they keep their people employed by
shipping us stuff stuff and we send them
green paper back. The, the economics
of this is quite crazy, uh,
altogether because they can never use.
What's interesting is they basically can
never use the money that we send them,
that if they have trillion
dollars or so in, in us bonds,
and if they ever tried to sell them,
the value of the dollar
goes to zero and there's,
they have to sell them for
nothing. Anyway, that's a
separate story. It's crazy.
A lot of causes or reasons
for globalization, number
one is shipping costs.
The whole idea of the shipping
when it went to containers,
the cost of shipping something from
China to the west coast of America, uh,
dropped drastically.
Ships carry an awful lot.
The water floats in Lacrosse
and they just have to,
the only energy that's used is to, is
to get, get over the friction of the,
of the water that they go through. Even
many years ago, I was in Bolivia and,
uh, discussing with an aid guy, you know,
Bolivia is very poor. What can they do?
Well, they have the mountains,
but then they have a jug,
a sloping down to the Amazon
where they could grow rice. Very,
very good agricultural land.
And uh,
and you know,
why can't they give that to like Lima
or to La Paz Lima in Peru where the
importing rice.
And the problem was that the Chinese can
grow it in the Yangtze valley floated
down the river to Shanghai,
put it on a boat and ship it and deliver
it to Kyle Lima's port cheaper than the
Bolivians were right next door to
Peru can truck it over to the Andes,
sorta go up and down and up
again and down again. Sorry.
And they have to ship
it to get to the coast.
They have to ship it over to
peaks of mountains on lousy roads.
And trucking is just very inefficient.
So it's cheaper to get the thing from
15,000 miles away up in such one, uh,
than to get it next door from
the Amazon slopes of Bolivia.
So shipping costs is very important.
And of course for white collar jobs,
telecommunication. Now, you know, we
used to say, oh, well let's let the low,
the cheap labor manufacturing jobs go
to China. But now China and India, uh,
we're in
immediate contact by telecommunications.
So the white collar jobs are going there,
the engineering is going to India, the,
uh, uh, the accounting is going to India,
the call centers have gone to India,
other jobs are going,
uh, going to China. So
this,
what happens to population,
I think in the longterm view and
longterm means 25 or 50 years,
we're not talking a thousand years.
Probably the one most important thing
which will determine the future of the u s
economy is what happens to
population in China and India.
And you could include
Indonesia and the rest of Asia,
but as long as they have an incredible
number of people willing to work for
incredibly needing to work for incredibly
low wages, we can't compete with them.
There is no economic
reason why an American, uh,
should earn a $40 a day or something.
And we got plus benefits and that's a low
wage for an American. Whereas you know,
a third of China that per capita income
is about a dollar a day for the lowest
third of China.
And that means the worker makes two or
$3 a day and there's no way that we can
earn without benefits that we can
earn 40 or $80 depending on what your
calculate and other people
in the world earning three.
So jobs are going to continue to go to
China, not only from the United States,
they're leaving Mexico. Uh, I
told you the story in Thailand,
the jewelry business in
Thailand that moved to China,
that there's just this vast,
vast sea of people who are desperate
to work for basically $2 a day.
Further thing that happened in the nouns,
a few hundred million people
floating around the cities.
Migrant labor is trying to get jobs
and now with the current economic class
being thrown out of jobs,
but Chinese agriculture is incredibly
inefficient as they told you.
The average farm size there
is, is, is one quarter, uh,
no 0.1 acre in,
in China.
And that's just
economically unsustainable.
The average farm size in the world is
for in Japan, I'm sorry, it's 400 acres,
I think. No, I'm sorry.
In we're at 400 and a u s and economic
us farmers like thousands of acres,
a big farm.
So we're talking about that eventually
China is going to have to compete in the
agricultural world on an even
footing with the rest of the,
which means their farms are going to
have to combine and that's already
happening. People are voluntarily
sort of pooling their land, uh,
having big things,
enough of the land to make it worth
them to buy a tractor and so forth.
So this economic, a rationalization
of agriculture is, is happening.
But think of the numbers there.
You have 800 million peasants with uh,
with like 1.1 acre each. When you
combine it even to a hundred acre farm,
which is still a small farm worldwide,
that means you combined a thousand
farms into one. In the modern world,
a thousand a hundred acres can,
is probably farm by one or two people.
So you go from a thousand
families living on 0.1 acre, each,
two, maybe two families living on a,
on a hundred acres of a combined farm.
That means that something like 99% of
the population of the countryside has to
get jobs somewhere else.
So if you have 800 million peasants and I,
you know,
almost 800 million new people are waiting
for these economic changes to come on
to the, the modern job
market. And so there's a,
there's a vast number of people waiting
that are now competing with us in every
other industrially advanced country
and who will continue to wait with us.
Uh, the Chinese government is well
aware of course of all this stuff.
And October last year, uh,
previously I don't, you know,
they don't really own their
land and they still don't,
but they did what they call a land reform
and the plan allows farmers for the
first time to lease or transfer
their land use to someone else.
Basically the Chinese are now allowed
to sell their farm, which will ease.
Now they have to have very complicated
collective arrangements where everybody
is sort of still there.
But once you can basically sale
or alienate your land in some way,
then you can totally leave the
land and go into the cities.
So the government has started
encouraging this kind of push.
What they'll do now with the
economic collapse. I don't know. Uh,
but uh,
it's,
we have a long way to go
before the population issue
in China is settled and our
fate and all of the developed
world depends very much
on what happens in China.
So just to finish, uh, the
Chinese have, have, you know,
the achievement of the Cha of,
of China is just mind boggling that in,
in a half a century they took people from
extremely poor country devastated by a
over a hundred years of war.
And now it's becoming one of the first
juror rank countries in the world.
And before this all started, no one would
have thought this was possible. I mean,
if you can read the literature of
that time, China was w was hopeless.
It was tech to fertility,
which you'll see is a very important part
of the whole story of economic success.
Uh, they're, they're, they're declined.
The rapidity of their decline to get a
country like China to drop its fertility
and 10 years is, is just an
amazing, uh, achievement.
Um, the judge, just incredible. Now,
now we want to get onto
this, this next question,
uh,
of that a student asked last time when I,
when I was saying the Chinese,
remember the Chinese started this
population thing for economic reasons.
They said we're are popular,
are our economy is going along.
We're increasing, like I
said, agricultural production,
what was it, 2.5% a year,
which is very good,
but population is growing 2.3% a year.
So we're not helping the people.
So it was very overtly stated that the,
the one child policy was
to improve China's economy.
They want to improve the
standard of living of the people.
At the time when they started this policy,
the standard of living
in China was very low as,
I don't have to tell you that uh,
health care was, was very, you know,
it was certainly better than it had been,
but still a very low level education,
uh,
was not widely available below the
very early primary grades in China.
So basically as the Chinese perceived
at themselves and as they, they,
they talked about it quite a bit.
Their children are growing up,
unhealthy and uneducated.
And when the Chinese talk
about economic development,
it's not only manufacturing more stuff,
which they basically are not too
interested in. They ship it to America.
They were primarily incident, what
they called the quality of the people.
They thought their population was
not of the quality that they wanted.
And quality means health and education.
They,
they wanted that their children were
growing up, not healthy and not educated.
And they, like everyone in the world
realizes that uneducated, sick children,
sick adults don't,
are not very productive.
And Western economists for a long time
considered capital as physical capital
and your factories and
machines that you have.
And the idea of human capital is fairly
recent and is now come massively into
vogue in the west.
That one of the most
important determinants of the
wealth of a country is one
country rich and one country poor is not
resources is not your physical capital
base,
but your human capital base.
So partly we've learned that
from the Chinese, you know,
I mean we learned it ourselves,
but also the Chinese example
is a very good example of this.
And just to give you an example of what
happens when people don't have education
in this particular case, biological
education is a story from again,
the year 2000 so from
not that many years back,
this is a firm do, who was a
local official in a small village.
He said one day there were hundreds of
people lined up at the entrance of our
village.
Oh,
I thought it must be a vegetable
market or a movie coming in.
It turned out to be blood selling.
I felt so terrified because there was
no sterilization equipment at all.
So this village official
had some education.
He understood about sterilization and he
had seen these blood campaigns before.
No sterilization villagers just tell
the traffickers their blood type if they
know it. If not, they make it up.
The village is just tell the traffickers
their blood type and then lie down on
the ground to offer blood.
What is the result of this avast aids
epidemic in these rural villages that are
doing this because they used the same
needle to repeatedly take blood from
person after person that he's lying up
on the ground and they stick one needle,
take the blood.
Needles are so expensive.
The apparatus for collecting
it as expensive so they,
we use the same needle and of course when
you use the same needle from person to
person,
the odds are if one person gets it,
the next ones are going to get it.
But actually the transmission rate by
blood to blood contact by a needle is
something like one in 200
it's not terribly efficient,
but what do they do with the blood?
They collect blood from everybody.
Then instead of keeping it individually,
which is expanded,
they dump it in to a big that they
pool it, they take it to the city,
they extract the components that they
want, which is the Gamma Globulin,
the clotting factor,
and a few other components.
And then they have a lot of blood left.
And what do they do?
They go back to the village
and reinject the blood,
the remaining blood into the people.
So now you don't just have a needle stick.
You've got pint of someone else of a
mixed blood of everyone in the village
going into your, your veins.
And now for sure, if any,
anyone in the village has aids,
you're going to be infected with it.
Do Continue.
The villagers become crazy about selling
blood because they are so poor and life
is so hard. Uh, many had built
their houses by selling blood.
Someone, even bribe traffickers to
be able to sell more than once a day.
The traffickers rooms and giving them
back blood because then they'll make more
blood.
They can sell more blood again.
But the people want to sell more
than a pint. Uh, in each day.
So they kind of lie and fake
cause their support. Uh,
the officials estimate something like
600,000 HIV cases that's probably nowhere
near near correct. The Bud
collections, uh, starting in the,
uh, in the 90s, was protected
by corrupt officials.
This was of course against public policy,
but it may have infected a million people.
This blood selling in
Henan province especially,
and virtually all of them are poor
peasants who sold the blood to make money.
So that gives you an idea
again,
of the status of education,
of the population and,
and,
and why human capital is so very important
because you're collecting blood cell.
The hospitals which will improve the
health was presumably of some people who
receive the blood,
but not if they get aids.
And while you're helping a few people who
have transfusions, uh, you're, you're,
you're infecting a millions
of people, uh, uh, with eight.
So you're making things totally worse.
Okay.
So does cutting your population.
So China had the idea and not alone,
that if they reduced their
population growth rate,
their economy will improve. And, uh,
is this true or not? Is this true? Uh,
most economists at the time, uh,
would certainly have said no.
Um, the eye that's a mouth through
Z and idea that population,
uh, that, that economic
development is limited by, uh, uh,
by population growth.
And people had thought to the industrial
revolution had sort of gotten rid of
them all. First Mothers' was irrelevant
marks as I mentioned last time,
hated morphous Marxism,
totally opposed.
And so a lot of the world's opinion
was that no population growth was not
detrimental to the economy.
And in fact,
they believe that population
growth was good, uh,
for an economy because it increased
market and everybody wants to increase
market,
um,
that you can do efficiencies of
scale and all kinds of reasons.
That growing population was considered
to be a wonderful thing. Businessmen,
especially in the capitalist economies
love population growth because the
population of the United States
runs is now growing at 1% a year,
which is less than it had been,
had been one and a half percent or so.
And the economic growth rate is about 3%.
So at my, at best and a very good year,
in a good year,
it's 3%.
So population growth and population
growth at 1% or one and a half percent,
if you're a total economy
is growing at two or 3%,
population goes is half the
increase in gross national product.
And that means it's half of
company profits. When you
have like General Motors,
it was counting every year on population
growing and being able to sell more
automobiles.
So that was,
that was basically the idea that
the pup, that growth was not, uh,
not a bad thing. But in 1958, uh,
to, uh, American, uh,
demographer economist had a different
idea because they looked at the developing
countries which had
enormous population, uh, uh,
enormous population and very high growth
rates and they weren't doing so well.
So what's with this theory,
they should be doing wonderfully.
They should be improving tremendously.
And they came up with a different
understanding of the relationship between
population and economics and this
based on some very simple economics,
uh, that economic development
requires investment.
If you want to produce something, you've
got to build a factory that takes money.
Where does that money come from? That
comes with someone else? Saving someone,
earns some money, might as Labor
or by whatever earned some money.
He can either spend that right away or
he can put it in a bank and then the bank
will invested forum where you can put
it into stocks or something like that.
So investment in a country within some
kind of economy investment requires
savings.
One person has to save so that
another can spend it as an investment.
They borrow that.
And um,
so that's the key. That's the key
idea in everything. Uh, that, that,
that follows with Coolen Hoover
realized is that if you have,
if a family has a lot of children,
if all the workers are married
and have a lot of children,
all of their income goes for food,
clothing, shelter to support the children.
They can't save any money.
If a country has no savings,
they don't have any money to invest. They
don't make any, uh, economic progress.
This had a big political effect.
This theory was,
and it seems so simple and so obvious,
but it apparently they had good
empirical sport. They studied, uh,
Mexico and then a couple of
other countries and showed
that this really seem to
be, uh, the case. Well, at that time,
the third world was the population
explosion was happening and they were
desperately poor. And so there
were two groups. One, uh,
conservatives were at that time
worried about the cold war.
America was locked in the Cold War
with communists. And I know China,
Russia, but especially Russia was,
was our big enemy at the time.
And we saw that all these
desperately poor countries,
the governments were not their
current economic and political,
so that we're not giving
them what they want.
They were poor and getting poorer as they,
as they perceived it.
And they were trying out all kinds
of different political solutions,
some of which were leftist.
So in America,
there was a big push by conservatives
mayther the anticommunist to do something
about the third world to save
them from communism. Meanwhile,
the liberals were less involved in this
us versus them kind of controversy,
but they sold these poor people in the
world and wanting to help all the poor
people. So they thought we should do
something about all these poor people.
And the answer was economic development,
economic development was universally
approved, uh, in America.
Oh by everyone as either a benevolent
act to by someone who considered
themselves liberal or by a self saving
anticommunist act by someone who
considered himself a conservative.
Well, once the cool the,
the,
the coal whole Hoover a paper came out
and people started realizing the Abi what
was considered to be the
obvious at that time,
it was very clear that family planning
programs had to be a part of economic
development. That these countries,
just these booming populations,
and there were televisions is full
of stories, especially about India,
how it was starving people in India. China
was kind of close to us at that time,
but India was open.
What a desperate situation that was
in India and India had quite leftist
governments and it was India
going to go communist, et
Cetera, et cetera. So, so, uh,
both sides of the American sort of the
whole political spectrum believed in ha
economic aid to the developing
world and family planning aid.
And it turns out that George Bush,
the senior,
the first George Bush president when
he was a congressman who was one of the
sponsors of the very first
family planning bill,
not only for domestic family planning
but also for international aid, uh,
for family planning. There were, there
was, this is not a debatable issue.
Everybody agree with it. And it was really
due to this economic thesis by, uh, by,
uh,
by colon Hoover and you,
you've read some of Ansley cold
stuff already now, however,
the economist keep working
in the scholars keep
going and what I'm looking for,
I'm going to get there.
Don't tell me I'm not going to get there.
Pardon my Greek.
All right, here's what I'm
looking for. Sorry for that. Um,
so what they did is they looked across
nationally and tried to figure out,
is it really true that uh,
population growth rate would affect
GDP, the growth of gross
domestic product per capita.
It's basically per capita income.
And what did they find when they got
all the countries they could find in the
world? Here's the growth rate and
here's a per capita economic growth.
And what's the pattern?
Zero.
There is no pattern here.
So it looks like that
this was meaningless.
That in fact the coal,
the coal Hoover hypothesis was wrong,
however nice the theory seemed,
uh,
you just couldn't get empirical evidence
for it. And that was terribly important.
Uh, again, again, a reversal.
Now Reagan administration comes in and
on the basis of information like that
says, uh, economic, uh,
population control is no benefit to,
to an economy's growth.
And we as conservatives are opposed to
government intervention in the private
lives of people.
So we're opposed to,
we're not going to give out
the anywhere near the level of,
of family planning aid that we
used to in the United States.
Went from a big leader in funding family
planning programs in the restaurants
are trying to discourage it.
We didn't drop to zero.
There were still some programs that we've
funded and they were very good by aid.
Uh, but we were the main discourager in
the world. We didn't like this whole idea.
And what,
what came up as an in opposition to this.
Uh,
and there was a big world congress about
population and development in Bucharest,
Romania at the time.
And the kind of data that came
out in this period is they,
um,
sorry,
they came out with the idea that the
way to get that it is good to have
fertility down for a lot of reasons,
but the way to do it that the causality,
the cool,
the coal Hoover causality is a reduction
in population growth will lead to
economic development because the
idea of the reverse causality,
not an increase in economic development
will lead to a decrease in, uh,
in, uh, in fertility. So the, the, the,
the slogan that came
out of this, um, this,
this Bucharest meeting of all the world
leaders is that development was the best
contraceptive that if you
wonder lower birth rates,
what you had to focus on was,
uh,
was economic development and that
became the map mantra for the world.
And the developing countries
have bought into that.
And it was very in sync as
just at that time, Romania,
the host of this thing was having the big,
the most extreme family planning program
ever, but in the opposite direction.
They,
at that time there,
it was a Soviet bloc country that
was doing poorly economically.
Their birth rate was very low.
Their mechanism of birth
control was abortion.
Four out of five pregnancies
were terminated by abortions in,
in Romania. For every one
childbirth there was four abortions,
Romania for not, not tracking, I'm
going to put for nationalist reasons.
They wanted a bigger, stronger Romania.
So they clamp down tremendously.
They abortion, clearly de legalized,
you couldn't get contraceptives anymore.
And the end result was that,
uh,
the birth rate temporarily fell,
but then the women establish networks
of illegal abortion and gradually,
uh, the birth rate rose, the birthrate
rose because they didn't have any,
any means, but it's, but very
rapidly, within a year or
two, they established, uh,
illegal abortion networks and the birth
rate came down and it never came down to
its original level.
And there's actually a fairly
big total effect of their policy.
But it was just the, the political, uh,
chicanery going on that,
that here Ceausescu who's running,
running Romania as a very strong communist
dictator who is doing a very strong
pro natalist family pop
policy. And but saying, no, uh,
the opposite won't work. You have to go
through economic development. Okay. So,
uh, but then the con then people went to
work on that theory and here's the data
that in this period of time,
these are the countries with slow economic
growth and their population growth
rate was about 2.6%.
And here's the ones with fast economic
growth rate and they're popular affect
Ferret, fast economic growth. And they're
the same in terms of population growth.
Here's you look some years later
and you have the same story.
Those were slow economic growth. Those
with fast economic growth have the same,
uh,
population growth.
So it is not true that
development itself acts as,
as a contraceptive.
Uh, but you look at it,
you spin the data at the
same data but a differently,
you look at those countries which
have slow population growth,
which are uh,
he's,
and while it wasn't an or fast
population growth with an UC,
does that affecting GDP?
And you're not seeing a big
effect here in this time frame,
but you are seeing a big time
effect in this timeframe.
Now something different is going on
that here, those countries is slow.
Population growth are
increasing economically.
Those countries fast population
growth are decreasing economically.
And the funny thing about this graph,
she said, what's the same data?
How can you come to opposite conclusions
but it's not the same day to spun
differently. This is the
population growth rate in 65 to 80.
And then the economic
situation, uh, 25 years later,
15 to 25 years later.
So something it looks like from this is,
is,
is not wildly conclusive data that
something about a population growth much
later has an effect on
your economic growth.
And that's what has now been
figured out to be exactly the, the,
the really important relationship
between population growth and economic
development. So you've seen
this graph many, many times.
This is a standard demographic
transition where the mortality rate,
the death rate falls first,
then after some delay,
the birth rate falls and your population
growth rate is this period when the
birth rate is way above the death rate.
Another aspect of that,
here's the same graph again appear
is that if you ask what does the,
the share working look like,
how many of these people working?
You'd have an idea called
the dependency ratio,
which is your number of workers divided
by your number of children and your
number of old folks. Well, in developing
countries the medical care is bad,
so you don't have, you can almost
ignore the old folks for, for,
for quite a period of time.
So basically the workers divided by the
number of children. And what happens, uh,
during this period is that,
uh,
as, uh, the, the,
the fertility rate falls,
what happens is you have a population,
we,
we've seen the population pyramid for
that with a number of workers in the
middle and then many more children
than workers made a, you know,
half again as many children as workers.
So each worker has to support like, uh,
each person in working age has to support
one and a half for two children of
children's age.
But then you get this fantastic fertility
drop as we saw in places like China,
where in in 10 years the fertility
comes down. And what happened,
this is your ball,
this is,
this is the big population of people sort
of age and there's no children coming
behind them, right? So kids are born,
you have a very high population,
kids are born,
then all of a sudden the population stops
having children basically, you know,
drops tremendously. But you still have
all the children born. It takes 15,
20 years for them to get into working age.
So once you drop your fertility,
you see no effect then because you still
have to support all those children for
the next 15,
20 years.
It's only after delay of 15 to 20 years
that you have this huge number of people
in working ages,
very few children behind them.
And the ratio of workers to
dependence becomes very good.
This is the people inside
this and the snake,
that's a takeoff on another.
You are here graph that I showed you
the population explosion. Anyway,
forget that. So here is,
you've seen this for China,
but here's for all of East Asia,
this be,
this is the death rate and the death rate
is really basically down by 1970 I've
showed you that for Egypt and all around
the world that the mortality rate, uh,
comes down fast and then it doesn't make
an awful lot of progress since then.
This is people aging.
So this is where we are now about 29.
So this stuff is all
guessing about the future.
But basically since 1970 the death
rate has been pretty constant.
But the birth rate comes down.
This big drop in the 70s. Again,
this is all of East Asia,
but primarily what you're seeing is
China's big drop in the death rate.
And so population growth narrows,
narrows, narrows down to almost nothing.
And presumably in the
near future, uh, the,
the death rate will climb
above of the birth rate.
So in looking at age structure,
this is a kind of a complicated
graph of they're very cute.
So this is sub Saharan Africa
as as a comparison, this
is the opposite situation.
So here this is like a piece of a pyramid.
This is your age group here you
have very few old people here.
You have in 1950,
this stripe is for the year 1950,
very few oldsters. This is your
working age population in here,
say from 20 to 60 or whatever
numbers you want to put.
And there's more children in
any age group than any of them.
You've seen the population per like that.
Now as time goes on in a
place like sub Saharan Africa,
that does not go through fertility
transition is that this shape have more
children than also just continues.
1975,
2000 2025, he began to
see they, they hope again,
this is where we're, we're at now.
This is all guessing about the future.
So up to now that shape have
more children. Oh No, no,
not doing it to me again. That shape
have more children. Uh, down here,
change stays unchanged. You're just
the whole population. It gets bigger.
It seemed that.
Now contrast that to
know it's working again,
contrast that to East Asia,
which in 1950 had what looks
like sub Saharan Africa has,
you know, many more children than
people in working ages. And again,
very few real old folk.
And then time goes on.
But then you start seeing
funny things happen where, Oh,
come on. Anyway, up
there, follow the, the,
so anywhere between 1975 and 2002,
the left and you see now the number of
children's starts dipping and up at the
top it dips a lot. And the bulge of, of,
of children becomes a
bulge in the working ages.
So when they have a lot of
people in working agents,
very few, uh, uh, children,
no oldsters yet.
So the word you don't have
anybody that you have to support.
And what happens is you
calculate this dependency ratio.
This is the number of working
age people to non working age.
And look what happens in each
east Asia. Uh, here's, here's the,
the, the, the, the, the,
the fertility decline is as soon as 10
years have passed, boom, boom, boom, boom.
The ratio gets to be wonderful.
And again, we're at this level,
we're somewhere near the peak.
This rest of this is guesswork
off to the right of that line.
So the dependency ratio just gets
better and better for East Asia.
And this has tremendous,
this is what has tremendous
economic consequences here is,
is the difference in the economic
growth per per year over.
Now this is a 35 year timespan suite.
We're not looking at,
a single year is tremendously
bigger than a place like Africa,
which has not reduced its fertility.
And we say this is based a lot
on savings and this you'll,
you'll have a reading about this,
which you won't like cause it's
somewhat complicated economics. But uh,
look at the savings rate in East Asia.
It goes from 1955 before
way before any of this,
14% to 35%.
It goes up like a factor of two and
a half or three tremendous saving and
investment. Then since you're
saving, you can have a,
an incredible increase in investment
which builds up your country economically.
Now the catch and this,
that savings equals investment,
you can also borrow money from abroad.
And so that's what they call
the current account balance.
How much money you can attract
from broad to to get developed.
And we in the West believe that it was
western capital that went into China,
loud them to build up and did wonderful
things. But no, it was never huge.
This is a 4.8,
uh,
less than 5% was the current.
Again, that's, that's a
minus sign in front of it.
That's what they're importing.
But very rapidly. By 1980,
uh,
they start to be a net capital exporter
that these poor countries have an excess
of capital and they now export. Uh, so,
so the development of China in particular
East Asia in general is not as you
would think, a result of west
infusion of western capital. I mean,
some of the early special cases,
Hong Kong and so forth clearly were,
but the main part of China,
they produce their own
capital because they're the,
the sequence of causality is fertility
decline. You wait 15, 20 years,
all those kids grow up, there's not
behind them. They all become workers.
You start,
you don't have children to support.
You start saving those savings become
investment and you become one of the
economic miracles are one
of the Tigers of the world
now.
Until recently,
this theory is about 10 or 15 years.
We've gradually becoming to understand
this idea about the economics and it was
thought to have something special about
Asia that yes, this was important,
but also the culture of Asia,
the, their, their propensity
to saving. Oh, let me see.
Go back up here. If I can
find that saving number. Um,
well the savings were it when China was
poured the savings, we're not fabulous.
They are fabulous now, but they weren't
then that's a result of being rich. Um,
so we thought there's something special
about East Asia and China in particular.
It's something cultural,
something cultural and that
when you did the econometrics,
you had to say you have to have one set
of prime. You can use the same model.
We have one set of parameters for,
for uh,
Asia and a completely different set
for Africa and another set for Europe.
When you don't consider the
demographic a situation,
once you put in the demographic situation,
we now know that the same
model fits around the world.
And it looks like that this
dependency burden is the key thing.
And one of the things that first clued
us into this was Ireland. So Ireland,
which is totally different culture
than in China had this, you know,
totally Catholic and they really
believed it. They used Catholicism as,
as fighting as a mode of fighting the
British. And so at a very high birth rate,
and they didn't have legal contraception
in 1980 the government legalize
contraception,
here's the birth rate,
just takes the drive and then after a
little blip continues downward. So again,
it's a government action of legalizing
contraception and the Irish birth rate
drops.
The death rate again is slowly going
down and then sort of not really going
anywhere in this period.
And so the population
growth rate decreases.
And again, this is the same
thing. You get the same effect.
The Irelands population looks
like China's smaller scale.
It's not anywhere near as big,
but again,
you have an underdeveloped
country looking thing.
It was a lot more children than
middle than workers are old people.
And then this continues going up until
you start getting this declining.
Now in this modern period,
currently,
there's a lot more workers in there
are either children or old people.
So the dependency burden looks real good.
This is the graph of that. The, the,
the purple curve on the bottom is
sub Saharan Africa, which again,
just consider what's up to the line
because everything else is guesswork.
And look here. Uh, the black is
east Asia and the green is Ireland.
Looks very, very similar. And
guess what the result is? Uh,
here's where they legalized birth control.
Boom,
the economic growth rate just Boone's
write up 10 or so years later.
And now comparing,
starting to compare this to India,
here is uh,
um,
China's growth per capita.
It started in 1960.
China was poorer than India by a good bit.
This is per capita income.
The red is trying to, blue is India,
1960, they're poor in 1970, they per 1980,
there poor once she shower, the, the,
the later longer few of
the fertility drop is in,
is in this period and it starts going
and then China takes off and exceeds,
uh,
India and is not due to the communist
government or a good government and cause
the, the, the, the kindness revolution
is, is way out here. And, and you know,
for a long time it was not
doing any better than India.
But the main event that happened
then is the drop in fertility.
And this shows you the difference in
China's fertility and India's fertility
that hears this Chinese drop starting
in 1970s and India slowly catching up,
but it's taking its time
about it. And this is the, uh,
the dependency burden here again,
the ratio of workers,
uh, to, to non-workers very,
really improving in China,
not going anywhere particular in India.
And when you compare it to
sub Saharan Africa again,
so we're comparing different parts of
the world to show you the story just is
the same. This is the birth rate,
the black and the and the death rate.
So a huge and continuing
population growth rate. Again,
up to the line. This is
guesswork out here. Uh,
and here is again,
you seen this before.
This is China's uh, east, I'm sorry,
East Asia's a dependency ratio.
Workers to children.
This is Africa's a huge difference
going on and they live in,
this is a situation.
So in sub Saharan Africa,
the working age population
has gone up 2.6%.
And even if you can keep
all those people employed,
when the dependent population goes
up 2.7%, you're not making any,
any progress where it's an East Asia,
still a significant dependent population.
They haven't stopped
having children altogether,
but the working age population is growing
half again as fast as the dependent
population.
That difference is what one makes you
rich and to makes you be rich enough to
save and invest and develop your country.
And you've gotten seen,
seen this graph,
the difference between East
Asia and Africa. All right. Um,
that, uh, is the main
idea that I wanted to get me. I have
to, by the way, on your schedule.
This lecture was supposed to be given
by David Bloom who's a professor at
Harvard and one of the guys
who did a lot of this work, uh,
he wasn't able to come.
So I use this.
He came in the last time I gave this
class and I use a lot of the slides or are
David blooms slides and uh,
he's responsible for a fair chunk of,
of this work. So, um,
all right.
So the end of this story is that,
again,
we talked about when I,
long time ago when I described
Algeria has how hard, how,
how much Algeria has gotten
their fertility down,
but their population is still and they
haven't been able to take advantage of
reduction in fertility.
The same thing happens with these
dependency burden issues because you first
have a lot more children than workers.
Then you stop having children and that
bulge grows and you get a lot more
workers than children.
But then those workers start to age as
the population decreases labels out.
So now you have the reverse situation
of a small number of workers in a large
number of old people
always independence burned.
You should add children
and old people. Uh, and as,
as your, as your fertility goes down,
your number of children goes down,
your number of oldsters goes up.
So it's not as bad.
It's not as extreme a change as possible.
But this would seem to incall call.
This is called the,
uh,
the demographic dividend
or the demographic bonus.
Uh, this, this phenomenon.
But it's a terminate.
There's a,
there's a time period when you can make
great economic progress and then your
people get old. And a lot of people leave.
Japan is in that situation right now.
There they have a very low birth rate
and the number of old people is rising.
And whereas in the past,
old people cost almost nothing
because just a little bit of food,
they didn't eat much.
But now with medical costs,
old people require lots of money.
And in the past children were expensive.
Old people were cheap. Now it's
reversed. The things that children use,
clothing comes from China's very cheap
food is comparatively cheap around the
world. I mean, forget the last
half year or something. Uh, so, uh,
so children used to be cheap
children. Uh, used to be expensive.
They're now getting cheaper. Oh,
people are getting very expensive.
So now the worry is that any country that
goes through a slow demographic change
and doesn't arrange its economics and
its politics to employ the people,
cause it doesn't do you any good.
If you have a whole lot of workers,
if they don't have any jobs,
and like Latin America for instance,
which is kind of an in between situation
was very protectionist or nationalist.
And uh, I, I can tell you
a story, but you know,
Bolivia nextdoor to Peru hadn't had so
much conflict with Peru that they didn't
want to form a carbon market with Peru
and they'd rather buy plastic buckets
from Brooklyn and rice from China than
they would to trade with their next door
neighbor.
So the story is that the,
the demographic situation seems to be
one of the major initiators of these
economic miracles that have
been happening around the world,
but they can't do it by themselves.
There has to be the economic and political
substructure to employ these people
to get, set them to work. And then a
country gets rich and when it gets,
once it gets rich, it gets the
capital that it can keep it going,
but you not have enough money
to invest and keep going.
Even though you may have to
spend a lot on your old folks,
you may be rich enough to generate
the excess wealth to do that.
Okay, so next time we'll talk about, uh,
economics. Then the family.
This has been macroeconomics,
how economics works on our
whole region wide thing,
but what its effect is on a family.